now waits the smacky head man yay I'm a
psychopath I just sniffed my own armpits
too
finally the skin matches the brain
I found something weird exploring on my
own about c2 there is a door at the end
that leads to zone 100 that is different
than any other door I've seen oh cool I
just got jump scared by the intro yeah
we can skip that I forgot the chairs
empty for you guys alright let's just
see one right run around full speed yeah
buddy
yes Oh long range my baby seafoam
grenades there
I have med kits so I will be mr. Medi
man all right cool yeah sucker eaten the
seafoam here no seafoam seafoam I'm long
gone one of you douchebags Chris I am in
another time zone I have my flashlight I
fine I'm assuming we're all just
splitting up to explore and just do your
own thing right it's all this big guys I
got this you don't have to kill
everything you come across man Marc
what's that how do you kill big ones for
people hit it at the station in the
corner okay so that's basically
impossible alright well his hand just
brushed me I know I know I know I know
how to do listen do you want to know a
pro strat of how to beat this dude sure
oh that seems like a really good idea
that looks good right there man I told
you that's what we're doing are we
swinging at him yeah [ __ ] it let's do it
yeah let's see what happens
charge now tried to jump on a barrel or
something like Kendrick Lamar no mark oh
yeah your legs on fire but you're a liar
you're gonna be put into a pyre I don't
know cuz his name is markiplier yeah
that's it that's why I got I got you
buddy I got you guys he's doing it again
who's gone me yeah my hero by Bob
Captain wrap over here me you must be
talking about me I got a med kit for you
funny or oh why here clickers hey we got
guys over here that's a lot of
squelching let's see what the deal is
behind this other door I'm making my way
to the other side of that room that
you're at just to see if I can help from
the other direction but there's quite a
few people in between me and that door
hmm
I love programming removes [ __ ] I drop
down a little ledge and I was like this
game over me
there's three kind of close to each
other though our guys weren't a lot of
whisper into each other and it creeps me
out yeah it's a little no dyes by
barrels sure sounds like you might have
died man I've been freaking out about
this game it's easy alright Sean I'm
coming to help Oh [ __ ] glorious day
I've committed to walking into this room
I do not like this
I mean what's something you're gonna
make when you get your brain caved in by
a makeshift sledgehammer
oh my brain oh my god I should get him
over here
with my friends oh listen going off and
your own aim for the faint of heart
balls of steel I regret so much of
what's happening right now
God wait one take away good head all
right everything on the other side of
that door is clear this is a few more in
this room that I'm gonna mop up I just
got the Scout I'm a wizard I can't
believe I didn't just ruin this no it's
fine it's fine it's fine it's fine it's
fine look it's mark I'm hearing alert
music it's fine it's fine look we're
fine when I say things are fine they're
fine
okay wait there's three here okay
working I think we're fine I'm gonna
choose to trust mark as I say not clear
not clear oh there's too many around me
for this to be a thing can you okay we
got to fall back to Bob the box no no
there's like four No
over here looks like where I got this
she's got this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you did got
it
okay good cuz this literally there's so
many in here and I'm still trying to
clear it out that will come back here
you're not invited I can I got one more
med pack I can give you fine it's fine
it's fine everything's fine don't worry
about it it's fine
I wasn't worried I'm such this out of me
being so relaxed I can barely handle it
it's fine I love that now all of you
have reached the level of confidence to
be like alright this area is now clear
toss friend we are safe and there's
there's a tool refill
wait just sure I'm gonna sprint what my
flash that on obviously that's how you
test I'm gonna go help them I guess I
can't believe I survived that I'm an
idiot behind the Scout and then the
Scout came toward me and I was like and
it totally worked out and nothing bad
happened I didn't even lose the elf
[ __ ] miracle you didn't even lose any
health by a barrel it was like speech
jammer Wade was talking at the same time
and I didn't know okay
sorry that might have it that might have
been made I didn't see on the other side
there sorry we're good now guess who
took damage terminal up here someone
with a bigger brain than me do it I can
do it you big
okay well what are we looking for we're
looking for Tupac's oh yeah P dicks list
P dick what zone is this over here this
door SEC door is to zone 90 okay good
news 90 has four of our objectives hey
that's a lot yeah where are you here
some in that room with you later yeah I
see at least one come here if there was
a reason there's one over on this side
to be able to see your teeny-tiny
testicles from here if you don't get in
there toxic masculinity is gonna get us
[Laughter]
how could I be upset so we should head
back to zone 9 to grab the four that are
in there yeah we need to go there
because the majority are in zone 90 98
99 there's a couple in other zones but
that's where the most of them are hey
you guys want to see some moves
oh oh oh there's a lot of nevermind I
don't have any moves you're being a real
[Laughter]
jock and murderin alright I had to clear
a whole bunch in a row Marc sit here
just pounding heads and we're just jerk
[Laughter]
right before the samos Wade Wade your
tiny balls get caught on a bear
stop don't judge don't kill a thing wait
don't worry about it it's fine don't
help or anything it's fine one too
you know good I was so busy pound in the
head when I came around the corner
weight was standing right here with like
three of them around him and he was just
like and no one came to help kill the
scout did you hear that guy who did
something forty years ago
is there enough glow sticks on the
ground I threw them everywhere
and there's some more glow sticks right
here if you need more everybody [ __ ] my
ass I don't need more [ __ ] in my hand
what most exertion it's wiser [ __ ] in
your hands so he doesn't watch it in his
hands that's this point how you gonna
get it out of your ass if you don't put
it in your hands he's got a point I feel
like the FPS of Wayne's Wayne's Brady
this doesn't love Wayne Brady honestly
oh it's Wayne's Brady I go by the plural
myself I'm left man I'm not guys go back
door oh they're coming in quick this
time okay yeah there's a common where
they are done right a few more looks
like outside my century there no I mean
the security is done we good god oh yeah
their colors
more and more yeah I don't know why I'm
wasting animal yeah that's a good cool
I'm picking I'm a century oh no that's
it we're good okay good job I see this
is it's a different spike room but yes
there are chargers or spikes in there
what you have an item was this [ __ ] oh
this game no I mean that's just the name
their name to get clothes from where got
one decoder oh alright do we hit him in
the where do we hit in the back in the
back okay that's all for them yep that's
good for bing bottom ranges let me see
is anything else in this room okay we
all we got all the stuff okay good good
that wasn't bad although there would be
more doors and [ __ ] this is just a
one-off yeah no that's why it's a it's a
blessing to give four in there see mark
that's what we should have done this one
first I mean yeah yeah mark
yeah idiot you're eating your own fist
oh can I get a tool refill real quick
just just one I think he'll be have one
on me if markets a tool I get a tool hey
you have 67% you've got the most wallet
jewelry felt okay I'm gonna try to
position my gun so it shoots him in the
back yeah we are we about to have to do
an alarm in here yeah do you guys think
two of those is fine for now
where should I put mine down I mean we
can just spread them out we don't need
to have to like always overlapping you
can just have them wherever Sean do you
want to touch my ass one time no wait
listen
you're like a medkit vacuum you just
keep we have limited resources and
spending them on keeping you alive you
come back to 20 after
that's far remember that's pretty far
wait give me in civil more than
one-fifth of a life anyway all right
what am i second from the right does
that mean what is this I don't even know
Oh God okay all right here they come I'm
gonna I'm gonna put my sensor in this
right hallway just in case so getting
danger-close I can't see [ __ ]
oh wow who hit me god yes they're all
here yeah they're danger oh they're in
oh my god [ __ ] trying to drop my century
real quick did not help
hmm it's feather it Stiller okay I think
maybe two centuries there would have
been good I said it could place it that
why do you need our rule to put down
your sentry we're a team goddammit and I
said that's a lot of noise that's
alright there's wander around and kill
him as at as you wish
they're well spaced around willy-nilly
even it's not a regular sleepy boy yeah
Wow yeah oh wow there's three down here
oh hey Mark you're hovering in the air
look at you well you know yeah yeah be
careful it just could take the stairs
down like I'm not Wade now come on no I
mean like the noise of drop you know Bob
you do you I'm gonna go for the middle
one here yeah I'm here with you all
right Bob you think in a diving
screaming like a bull attack I can dive
vomit yeah I'll start charging from up
here alright okay that sounds great all
right this is another one look behind
you mark uh I didn't see you I think
it's fine Bob wouldn't see it if there's
one over there
yeah all right it's fine we can get
these okay charge now three two one
like a little wider oh that one walk hey
whoa hey whoa oh oh he's woke and he's
dead it was the next room that we got
[ __ ] in last time right I think so
yeah the upward like the like an
upstairs little area we choose this one
I believe yep are these separate rooms
are these the same same room but we can
I'm gonna do this tour yeah over there
yeah I'll go with you Bob I'm opening
right I think we should all go that way
hey Fran how's it looking up there bub I
got one right in the door on the other
side of the room for me here across
there's five within close proximity p.m.
I can pop no doubt a regular sleeper I
can pop this guy yeah you got that one
yeah this is the the better route blew
out his ass these dudes oh I'm coming
did that happen running dude no we're
not dad down oh [ __ ]
well I think you guys have this now I'm
just taking a little nap I don't know it
was like not even alerted all right
everybody sorry Bob I think I might've
shot you at one point there wow this is
fine
all right is this room clear now
probably not least down here is I just
sprinted down here in my light and
nothing who need um we're all pretty low
so you say we're all about the same come
here friends get a lick from Jack
Parshall decoder did that work on you
wait yeah 240 okay he's a nice one you
picked a special I'm a [ __ ] talking
something oh I can show you the weird
door yeah wait come over here to this
door on the north side it's like I can
show you the funky door that I don't
know what it is and maybe it's the door
we need to get used all the things on
there might be things in here by the way
just FYI
yeah that sounds like there's things in
there oh right here right here they
decide five hit him hit him
the arrestor learning Alamo fight the
door yeah I used to door use the door
turn at the door centuries up watch out
mark it get in all avoid there not
enough [ __ ] that one was on my ass
before the news there yeah
one was him was hitting me through the
concrete wasn't is that is that what was
funky about the door there's a Mickey
there
I have tool refills I'm going to give
one to Posse toss want to Bam Bam and
okay check out the door on the north
side fog repeller
what a time to be alive it says it needs
a keycard it needs yellow six seven
eight which is weird cuz it's not like
it needs to coders or anything but it
goes to zone 100 but there's no PDX in
zone 100 I don't know what's in some 100
do you think about to escape through
that router some things that are their
traditional
maybe that's or maybe it's a secondary
objective once we have all the decoders
yeah I'm working on it I'm working on
this door I'll figure it out okay so if
I type list zone 100 there is nothing in
that zone it says there's no there's a
terminal in there and nothing else I bet
it's a special terminal what if there's
like a big boss somewhere the way this
literally is just be one isn't it these
lazy ass game developers hey the call 10
chambers not infinite chambers okay
unplayable so the yellow key is in zone
68 yes that was something that you
wanted to get but I also just want to
like clear this zone I've never sorry
998 for other interesting things in zone
98 there are three P decks well we need
those in zone 99 there are four P decks
that's this one it's an alarm door so
the other one we have the key for zone
96 96 has 298 it has three I say we do
96 then 98 we'll get the yellow key
which is also in 98 for the weird door
oh we'll have everything we need
where's the door for 96 it's to the
south is back yeah back in south put the
key in and see if it's alarm oh no no oh
nasty
yes there's two in here somewhere
found one I have a puppy deck in my hand
cool cool cool refill there's nothing
over did you guys do this room would you
guys just leave alone we're not killing
anything
don't kill things yeah just close the
doors on your way out and I think it
will be fine here well we can't close
the main door but yeah we use the little
doors close the main door in your mind I
pictured you guys naked instead is that
okay
depends on what kind of reaction that
got out of you one I can't share on
stream then yeah it's totally fine all
right my reactions not copper compliant
guys I can okay so they can only come
through this door right yeah and they
will come down the ladder that's that's
the thing or maybe yeah yeah I think I
think that laugh is a little excessive I
think all right everyone good on
sentries I would literally say they are
only gonna come down this ladder I
guarantee you so four on the ladder is
like just yeah I'll put mine right here
now get them no one's know you're here
to appreciate my joke look how funny
this is
if I may these creatures are weak from
the behind if if you find here there yes
that's him in there onus on us is that
what you're saying yeah that would turn
I don't know you guys do what everyone
I'm not in charge
mark you're put to the ladder you could
also put it up above okay here we go
you could also just
[Laughter]
I got it if it goes down it's going down
oh it's coming down it's yelling timber
right in front of this century that was
placed right here I see oh this isn't
left at all coming in it's coming in
where the Frick I don't know go back up
it's going back up going back up goddamn
fall damage for this
all right oh that did it oh oh why we
did it big guy
he's like dice stop that was easy
yeah it wasn't something bad that I
chose to take my fall damage when no one
was paying attention
if I fall damage bottom I totally make
fun of him because I don't know it I've
got a perspective which I only got away
with it and it's because I'm smart wait
look you are a much better recipient for
tool refill yeah I need to refill that I
know I know
god I hate upsetting the nice one I hate
it I hate doing it please
my favorite philosopher testiclees that
guy what the [ __ ] what wait what the
[ __ ] did he just pop in I think he was
there the whole time but holy [ __ ] get
there there's a sleeper in a crust oh
all right in the doorway they're both oh
my god chill that's your plan I I'm just
all about speed and efficiency here
right right right that's that big boy
man I'm gonna open this door just to see
what the deal is if it's worse than here
closes [ __ ] there's nothing here okay
this might be a safe zone if you guys
want you know what wait that wasn't your
fault the snobby maid was so ridiculous
it made me stop looking at the computer
so I shouldn't understand what happen I
don't even know what sound attention
those sincere Wade betrayal noise yeah I
went to the corner I cried a little peed
a little
you guys open okay cheering never Oh
yellow key card there's one more P deck
in here and it'll be the last one we
need are we sure it's in this particular
room not not like well it might be in an
adjacent room but it's definitely in
this zone I hear the tentacle guy on the
other side of this door here yeah is
there one maybe go check that area see
what the deal is
or I can just ping the the door player
what are you doing I said open this door
you ready do a clinger or whatever the
hell you said oh it's in it's in that
area
yeah oh yeah oh wait a minute oh that's
close
don't don't boy oh mama you need me
opinion on this yeah careful or I'll
just keep pinging it oh that's right
here it's right next to us Bob moving
again I feel like it's up is there up
yeah there's enough oh don't don't don't
I believe we need to reassess maybe just
one person go get it not me
I don't even or it is guys take the ring
to Mordor all right cool oh she's
beautiful
oh she could just came in from grooming
oh you're so pretty
oh listen there's stuff happening right
now
Wow okay I got keep streaming okay she's
beautiful what's going on got everything
the lights probably tentacles and things
what's up listen you need to call Marky
you did it I knew it all right I found a
door door door no idea not alarmed or
should we kill the stuff in that one
room first okay cuz it's all gonna come
at us isn't it Oh interesting
interesting interesting very interesting
our objective is now go to the forward
exit point so it must be through this
door that's what I'm thinkin I'm seeing
the extraction
[Laughter]
[Music]
would you please fill my tool no I don't
think so someone's given me a lot why
are you running away from me wave God
everyone's full except for Bob let's
just set your sentries out they're not
gonna trigger from this people come out
that room people will not get it out oh
I'm not saying a word do it every go
wait go in there you got this kill the
tentacle we it's necessary we should set
our turrets out and do the things you do
Mark's plan I like Mark's plan
thank you thanks here and the rest of
the ladder
[Music]
yeah wait you should set it up and fire
it this way like Mark said they take
damage I take damage in the booty in the
ass and the anus sorry people were
escalating the word in the brown store
and the gluteus maximus with the bass
hold the poops and the chocolate
starfish in the whoopsie love tunnel
tunnel
whoopsie if that's what you're aiming
for okay whoa there it is so it's so
slowly going lead a friend interesting
okay they're on the way oh my goodness
Oh what I bind it back oh [ __ ] good
shots one more one more one more I love
this one yep yep yep yep yep yep I'm
going for the far one okay another way
of coming in we're good we're good we're
good we're good
keep doing them all right no there's
another there's another oh my god I
don't see the path means resting we just
have to get back to the door
we need to enter the security scan to
progress where the [ __ ] is it up here
game if this is bugged I so every
convinced this says we can open the
security doors
oh it must be just the graphical thing
is gone we need to get to the extract
[ __ ] whoa yeah get to the door open the
door open the door get that [ __ ] open
open it
I press D on it don't worry I've got
this guys we're gonna win don't worry
guys we're fine look how well we can see
this hallway this is a problem playing
with a bunch of comedians over here a
bunch of haha
[Music]
I found the keycard nobody could find
remember where you got luck that say the
door solve the mystery
mark was like listen to me
[Laughter]
[Music]